hey guys I just got back from the
doctor's office I got my first physical
and ages yeah this morning I had to rush
out so I didn't even get a chance to do
my hair like this is me just getting out
of the shower I really don't like it cuz
oh my god I hate how it curls out anyway
see I got my blood drawn yeah I'm
getting some tests done because I just
feel like I haven't really been myself
like recently and like I've just been
really like fatigued my joints hurt like
I feel like my age is catching up to me
I was like alright I need to start
taking care of myself
start adulty cuz you know when you're
young you're just like yeah I'm fine
like I don't have to worry about this
stuff like I got plenty of time plenty
of time I know yeah now I'm home because
we're about to have a meeting with
Michael so if you guys watch just
kidding party then you guys probably
know who Michael is because he also
works with JK but Michael is our
business manager and he's also our
business partner because we partnered up
with him with that video course that
Casey mentioned in a previous video we
created this video of course to show you
guys how we blog so it's called life
with the camera and if you guys could
probably see the website here if you
guys want to sign up to our newsletter
and get notifications to see whenever
that's gonna be coming out that's gonna
be pretty awesome if you're interested
in learning how we block it so right now
we're gonna be having a meeting all
three of us to talk about Luwak we call
it a little walk you know life with the
camera low whack but anyway hi cutie pie
you wanna eat lunch with us too huh oh
my gosh you're so freaking cute you put
your paws you're so cute ooh
hi honey oh no it's good what's that
by something Mediterranean chicken yeah
because I have so much of the leftover
ingredients know how you go to the
grocery store oh yeah my stuff to make
one dish and you end up having like
enough to make like ten more of those
yeah so yeah I'm just trying to finish
up all the ingredients we have oh
there's no like maybe could get creative
and create different I wish it did
because I bought shitake mushrooms the
other day to to make some Chinese food
and I have a lot of leftover shiitake
mushrooms ginger stir them in here too
in Mediterranean cooking I'm always very
very very well aware that I'm a lucky
girl thank you but allamanda lagging
behind me is making me turkey anyway oh
thank
I've been talking to Casey and I've been
telling him how I've been very eager to
just change my life so cuz I please he's
happy about that especially since I
didn't grow up with homemade food I
gotta really see an importance that much
into home-cooked meals but then now that
you know I have this guy here he's been
cooking a lot and I've just every time I
eat his meals and I don't eat fast food
or junk food or anything for the rest of
that day then I realize like man I
really I do feel a lot better like
they're not lying like it is better to
eat healthy it's not so stupid but like
not until like I actually feel it in my
own body do I really notice the
difference and like actually appreciate
the truth and that and the fact that
though when you eat healthier you just
feel better big enough eating that's the
cat's food it's your lunch time - hi
Maya
you ready to eat your lunch okay you
don't like being watched
oh yeah you do you don't mind look at
you waiting like a gentleman waiting for
her to eat first
yeah huh he always waits for her to eat
first and then he devours the rest it's
like us
whenever I don't finish a meal you
always end up eating it for me gladly
all right now we're gonna you know it's
funny I literally just turn off the
camera because I was like we're gonna
eat but then look who's here
all on my cow hi Michael doing vlogging
sorry I've been parted too with the
camera sorry already where we just
started yeah I feel like really I should
come back in like 20 minutes
my doctor appointment took a little
longer
Oh would you the doctor for oh I got
some blood work done and told the doctor
some of my concerns
baby concerns no no no not does they
know every time you mentioned doctor
feel like everyone asked me oh no it's
not all right now I'm gonna eat sorry
all right so we're in the middle of
every little whack meeting do that what
is a little whack way
yeah it's life with the camera yeah it's
so hard to say little whack I like like
a kind of like a whack it sounds like
you're saying that's whack in French you
do it I like it though anyway so I'm in
the middle of this meeting right and
it's already like late afternoon and I'm
also trying to juggle balancing JK needs
because we're selling jakey news
tomorrow and then I just have guests
that bailed on me last minute and I need
to like scramble to find other people to
sit in and I'm like good
like always their last choice is how
little you see it no I'm just playing
yeah I'm playing no I totally I'm always
the last resort because I don't care
no okay so what happens here is whenever
I'm trying to find drinking news guess
we're trying to find people that can
obviously contribute to a conversation
right there are people that we call like
that are in health so people that work
with JK so that usually will have like
Ryan sit in or Brandon or aunt or you
know people like that but then there's
like my backup people like if there's
those people can't make it and I have
Katie in the back a person I'm third
string I think I don't like ten stream
there because I only got a call up like
once and then never again
Benchwarmers your water boy
I'm like back to the waterboy I was I
was under like what - never again it was
you tip like I see that was probably
like like at least over a year ago was
the last time I was ingesting news no
way damn that Moran remember the face of
the reason why can't seize the backup
and also Julia so the reason why Julia
the backup she was explain this before
how she just doesn't like being on Jake
Aeneas anymore so like she was like my
last resort like I really try not to
bother her because she just doesn't like
being on taking it so then Casey is like
but not above her because he's always
busy he's told he's also expressed like
he doesn't like being I'm taking news
that's why I don't want to bother you on
that and then also like you know you
have to pick up Isaac like those long
days that we have to film pass the time
I think it's out of school so I try not
to bother you at all and so right now
I'm like scrambling I'm like oh my god
they're just like two guests that are
out Bart and you are also out there on
vacation Randall so at least I got
Steven Nikki covering for that but I'm
like today is really stressful they can
work on lowering up to it I like trying
to like figure out like and it's that we
do do the project making sure that's
perfect for you guys once you guys
receive it on your end
oh yeah how do you feel about so like
I'm the one editing it and I guess I've
been working a lot more closer with
Michael look with this project and then
I've been you know busy with JK and I'm
not in JK news so not as busy with Jay
King yeah and you're just now watching
majority these videos for the first time
I know about it so I'm trying to view
this in like a third person eyes someone
that doesn't know anything about
vlogging someone that doesn't know
anything about editing another close to
the project I can't see what you see
well that's the thing that is perfect
let's launch it now and I'm like no this
doesn't make sense they're like we need
a bridge that with that or you better if
we see this with that so like that's
what I kind of like what my role is
right now and
with this project because we already did
the filming a really long time ago I
obviously I still have blue hair and
then like the whole in-between of you
know Michael set up the whole website
and then they've also both been
coordinating with people who've been
editing this because you know Casey's
been really busy and edit the entire
thing so we've had other editors ghost
Landers yeah it goes there's like that
woman with this project and then also
like coordinating Michael is one of the
ghosts
oh yeah we are you know making sure that
alike Casey is doing final approvals of
all the edits and making sure things are
clean so that it's like you know he
wants to make sure that it's just out to
make sure you guys get what it is done
you know he does yeah so then I'm trying
to view that with that lens right and
it's really hard to do it with that
length because I dunno what every what
we're teaching I'm like yeah that's what
does a common knowledge right so it's
kind of hard to put myself and that
third-person perspective all right we
finally finished our meeting we're gonna
be discussing our lunch dates gonna be
so exciting make sure to sign up to that
newsletter
anyway Casey's gonna go pick up Isaac
right now I have to really really do
Jake he knew studying really quickly and
update I found my guest so now I'm okay
you guys dorks anyway yeah so now I got
a dude jacking you studying
[Music]
ha my boy hi cutie pie how's your day
yeah you're sweaty you're a sweaty kid
now I know I mean he's kind of one
what's their body odor
come on guess what tell me engine start
oh and then just start I like that look
- you look like a ninja
how do you make it yeah go get one look
at this fat boy why is it so fat believe
fat boy hurry
it's bet yeah you're a fat boy have a
hard time telling me if dogs and cats
are fat or not because they're still
fuzzy they just kind of like like you
monkey more sweaters you can't really
tell if they're fat or not I used to be
like pretty heavy I mean the heaviest
ever was is 180 in back with knives
morning whoa you're 180 help you know
how much I weigh or now how much 140 140
pound difference I was 180 though I used
to wear live sweaters struggling
[Music]
like this you're so mean alright show me
my boys alright so we need oh that's for
me here you scissors for this it could
rip it Oh origami right you gotta have a
square piece of paper I knew that I like
licking it and then folding it over the
part where or folding it and then
licking it and then bending into the
breaks fold it and you fold it the other
way so you have like a weakened part of
the paper and then you lick it no but no
no no you have to keep it folded and
lick it
fold it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we're gonna start supper huh this is
supper all right so I just help Isaac
redo his ninja star so look you know
just a little bit neater my niche star
has perfectly Oh your ninja star has
been mommed like that time to eat your
supper ah silly all right remember those
uh kalamata olives we've got in that one
other vlog well Isaac wasn't a big fan
of it but he wants to give it a second
chance
well I gave him one olive right on the
plate and then I also poured a little
bit of brine and cut because he was like
what's the juice like and I was like
it's not juice it's actually Brian's
really salty so you're not gonna want to
try it but he still wants to try it so I
poured a little bit in that Cup it's not
a little bit as a lot
it's a shot don't drink it what is a
brain salt and water in short another
spices in there I'm sure but really he
Jeremy deficient I don't want you finish
it's too much salt it's not good for you
can almost see it like alcohol like
that's how strong sleep right because
it's apartment it one of those like
[Music]
like spew water it's like going to the
ocean in just like yeah black but that's
you hunter mean by not bad Oh what's
happening here
so you guys collab as a band that is so
cute never ban Isaac in the Casey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
high-five baby high-five it's okay
that's why practice is important so what
song are you guys working on song
without words if you know anything you
always have to do that riff every time
you have a good time I love it baby
for as long as I know you you know like
on our first date you were playing the
guitar you had to play that riff - all
right closes close us out baby play
something to close out this vlog as a
goodbye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
clapping the holding the camera you
could clap you have to then alright baby
give me an outro for this video is that
our outro song I think so
[Music]